hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about what to do when you get
frustrated in your language learning
it's a subject that comes up all the
time before I get to that though I just
want to tell you that I have a very
pleasant duty tonight I'm judging a I
guess it's a beauty contest it's Miss
Chinese Vancouver ten Chinese Canadian
girls from Vancouver who are competing
for this Miss Chinese Vancouver title
and the winner will go on to a Miss
Chinese international competition in
Hong Kong and so last week I was one of
four judges that got to interview these
girls and have dinner with them and
today is a big gala event where they
have to you know show off different
dresses traditional Chinese dress or
whatever I think it's a swimsuit thing
here as well and I've got to kind of
judge them out of ten for their
personality their how whose most
photogenic who's you know answers
questions well and so forth and so on
and we got a nice dinner out of it so
yeah I wouldn't have that opportunity if
I didn't speak Cantonese and Mandarin so
there's a another you know advantage to
learning languages but um recently you
know I guess very often I get the
question you know people say well you
know I've I've run out of motivation I'm
not motivated to learn anymore what
should I do this comes up on our forum
at link from time to time there was also
question on our forum someone who is a
student I think in Poland was saying
that her teacher or his teacher her
teacher had asked for her to they she
had to do a test where she has to
identify whether words are formal
informal colloquial um you know academic
or whatever words so I looked through
these two things together and I thought
to myself you know my that my I think
when I did this the video is the seven
secrets to successful language learning
either number one or number
two important secrets were do the things
that you like to do I think the second
one is to spend the time okay so those
are the two big things because it comes
back to the basic idea that language
learning success depends on your
attitude largely and on the amount of
time you put it those are the two big
factors so if you do things that you
like doing that you enjoy doing you're
likely to continue and if you enjoy
doing them you aren't worried about
whether you're meeting some arbitrary
goal I have to be fluent in six months
three months ten months it doesn't
matter you enjoy doing what you're doing
so if I take the example of my check for
example I have had two conversations now
in check I started the check in early
August I've had two conversations with
two of our native speakers at Linc and I
did very poorly I mean struggling to
find words either I didn't have the
words or in many cases I knew the words
but I couldn't recall them um but I
don't find that in any way discouraging
I don't find that in any way
discouraging because what I do with my
check I thoroughly enjoy and I am
reading a book now which is called I've
been at it for a while Sydnee of ropa
vieja I've mentioned it before and I've
been at it for a while you know you
probably can't see this but when I read
it there's all kinds of words in there
that I underlined which I don't know and
then I in many cases pumped them into
link if I'm if I'm up to it or I don't
but I have learned so much about the
history of basically Eastern Central
Europe Poland Hungary and Czechoslovakia
and I'm gathering more and more steam
and my Czech learning I enjoyed it's a
pleasure to go there I also go to my
iPad and there I've got again I don't
know if it's going to be visible or not
but here I've got you know the good
soldier shake and you can see that
there's lots of words that I don't know
and it
in Eiling so if I click on a word it
shows you the meaning at the bottom
you'll see there's a sound bar I can
listen to it
I even have these things in a playlist
so that I just go to it and it's fun
I don't worry about how well I'm doing
and when I don't feel like doing it I
don't do it but those are things that I
enjoy doing with my Russian now I'm at
the stage where I just listen in to echo
my speed because I want to hear the
commentary about you know the recent
elections and things like that but I
don't listen to as much as I used to but
when I do listen I know that all of my
exposure to the language is improving me
so I'm not like that student in Poland
who has to pass a test where you know I
have to identify which words are of this
category or that category formal or
informal or colloquial I can't imagine
that doing that because first of all we
know that the vocabulary in most
contexts is is is 80% 70 to 80% the most
common words of the language so it
doesn't matter what the context is in
formal formal academic business it's 80%
same words so that doing the reading
those exposing yourself to any content
is going to be beneficial I also feel
that to identify a word as informal
formal academic it's very difficult
because if I say in everything all the
words that I'm using in this
presentation this discussion which is a
fairly casual discussion but on a
serious subject all those words can be
used in an informal situation can be
used in an academic paper
I think this poly student said that her
teacher told her his or her told her
that she was not to use phrasal verbs in
academic writing and she was not to use
long phrases like on the one hand on the
other hand in academic writing well to
me writing is writing languages language
and the objective in writing is to be
clear simple and straight
forward unless you're writing a poem or
you're describing beautiful scenery but
most of the articles that we write and
most of our communication we want to be
simple and clear and straightforward and
that's true whether we're speaking or
whether we're writing so I don't see
that all these big differences are all
that meaningful and if I want to get
better at say academic writing then I
read more academic articles but that'll
only work if I'm interested in the
subject very difficult to do if you are
going to try to become better at writing
on veterinary science and you're not
interested in veterinary science you'll
have a real tough time but if you're
very interested in that subject or
chemistry or computers or anything else
and you're reading that stuff all the
time you will naturally acquire the
language the terminology the style that
you need so you know if you stay with
doing things that you enjoy doing and
follow your interests and your interest
can move and you'll go through periods
where you're not so interested and if
you don't always have to look over your
shoulder and say to you know I need this
for my test or am i progressing fast
enough or right you know don't worry
about it like I I owe and that reminds
me you know I was with this other person
a Chinese person who has lived in Canada
for over 10 years and doesn't speak
English very well and and as I was
trying to persuade them they should
really make an effort and they said yeah
yeah yeah but you know I always forget I
was free of course you forget everybody
forgets I mean the number of times you
know in my in my Czech history book here
that I underlined the very same word the
word that I looked up and I forgotten
and that's of course why you make we
highlight them in yellow because you
forget you forget you forget it's all
about forgetting and but with enough
exposure with enough exposure slowly the
brain will learn so if you stay with
things that you enjoy doing whether it
be reading or listening or going out and
talking to people but the bulk of that
is still going to be listening if you
don't speak very well if you're in
conversation with someone you don't have
much to say they have a lot to say and
getting it straight from a native
speaker you know
interactive situation is very very
positive speaking as well I mean I tend
not to do it at first because I don't
have so many words but I know very well
that even those two sessions with a
native speaker on Lync I saw in gaps I
saw words that I knew I that I that I
have and I wasn't able to find them and
and so being confronted with these gaps
in my skills it helps me notice things
it helps me notice and the next time I
came across those words in my reading I
made a particular point of noticing them
so all these different activities are
helpful and if you enjoy reading grammar
by all means read it but if you don't
enjoy reading grammar you don't need to
or you can limit it as I do to the
occasional flip through to see what you
might might glean without trying to nail
things down so I just want to say that
on this issue of you know what happens
when you get frustrated well why are you
frustrated don't worry about how fast
you're progressing be confident that if
you do things that you enjoy doing in
the language and if you stay with it you
will progress you will progress faster
if you do things that you enjoy doing
then if you try to force yourself to do
things that you don't enjoy doing
I have no scientific research to back
that up but I think that's a pretty
common-sense conclusion that I've drawn
from watching people because the vast
majority people who try to force
themselves to do things that they don't
enjoy don't end up progressing very
quickly in the language and those people
that do enjoy what they're doing also
make progress so there you have it how
do you avoid getting frustrated don't
even think about getting frustrated just
do the things that you enjoy doing in
the language thanks for listening bye
for now